so we're in sort of a weird transitional
phase right now because beginner
breakdown is being phased out and coming
up shortly here we'll be doing a
strategy class the working title for the
moment is strategy sessions with
Jonathan trance you can expect that
coming next month so we'll do you know
something a little bit a bit different I
do want to read what a Mike comer has
already written for the description of
my new strategy class that'll be coming
up pretty soon it's pretty it's pretty
epic it's classic Mike comer Jonathan
Schwanz will guide you to superstardom
with excellent strategic strategies
suggested rating 1,500 and below so we
will be discussing in the upcoming weeks
some strategic strategies so if you were
if you were looking for some onion
strategic strategies that'll have to be
a different class so that's what that's
what I'll be happening soon and you at
home you could influence this class if
you've got a good catchy name that has
strategy in the title alliteration is
preferred then I'll let me know and
maybe you'll influence the course of our
YouTube channel forever so uh okay but
today we will sort of keep it old-school
begin a breakdown style and we'll
analyze some games I had a several
people request some games so we'll we'll
go over them a gentleman named Greg sent
in two of his games so we'll go ahead
and go over that first some people in
the audience sent in a game so hopefully
we have time to get to that one too and
okay Greg said some some nice things
about the show and then he said so this
is one of the games he wrote so I was
going to go over my blitz games and such
stuffs from lie chests and old games
from my first tournament I found two
games that Jonathan could analyze on his
next episode of analyzed this which
could be the name of this class nobody
really knows at this point we've had a
class called analyze this in the past so
who knows first game I had white in a
5+2 game so it was five minutes plus two
second increment is what it sounds like
so a relatively quick game and we'll
jump to it here we'll see Greg had the
white pieces and he played efore very
good and we got a Sicilian all right so
so far it's looking pretty exciting
all right Knight f6 d6 and we do get an
open Sicilian very good this promises to
be exciting and I will see what
variation we get here in just a second
and okay in this position there's so
many moves a 6g six last night we looked
at the movie six for those that were
here for that class but the classical
variation was chosen in this game okay
Knight to c6 very very good looking move
and okay this move strikes me as a
little odd now what was played here by
white white played the move Bishop to e3
so it's it's sort of like an English
attack this is very popular against the
knight or if it's very popular against
the Chafin ingen which of course I'm not
pronouncing right but you know what I'm
talking about instead of the knight on
c6 you played them of e6000 a six so it
looks like it's it's gonna be a shave
inning and after all which is nice we
just talked about that last night so
that'll be interesting okay I think of
this this move are supposed to be met by
this move Knight to g4 which is what you
typically want to think about whenever
you whenever they put a bishop on e3 and
obviously when you don't have a pawn
here so your knight is protected and
knight Knight to c6 it's just a better
move in these positions in general than
to move a six so even after some normal
moves that you might see in a knight
orff
this sort of thing happens all the time
but now this move comes with tempo
because you're attacking the knight on
d4 and I mean I don't really know all
the theory I just know this is how
you're supposed to play this position
and okay so it should be a relatively
better version then you would get if you
played some other sicilians
and I think here that the two moves are
either Bishop e6 and you can even
consider the crazy-looking Bishop takes
c3 which okay you're giving up a very
important dark-squared bishop but it's
actually a playable line for black but
let's go see what happened so instead
that that
that didn't happen the game of the move
in the game was six so yeah so we get
started the same inning and pawn
structure that we're that we're now very
familiar with and okay so I think if he
wants to play in typical you know
English attack style he should play the
move f3 here followed by Queen d2 and
castling queenside and then g4 h4 and
you attack on the Kings side and if
black castles over there you hope that
you checkmate him that's the common way
he decided instead to go for a plan with
f4 so we would lead to just sort of the
classical lines that we saw last night
if we just played Bishop to e2 followed
by either f4 castling and then f4 so I'm
wondering if there's any way to possibly
take advantage of the fact that Bishop
e2 wasn't played just yet so perhaps if
there is a way to try to punish this it
might be a move like 'if I've the point
is now I can play Knight to g4 in a lot
of cases here so uh you know whatever
you whatever you do here I'm gonna play
Knight to g4 okay if I I would probably
look at that if I didn't really see that
that worked at all I'd play what was
played in a game Bishop e7 ok very good
and I move we haven't really talked
about before but I move that makes a
little bit of sense here I think a
little queen to f3 and we saw last night
okay often the Queen will maneuver to
the g3 square where she puts a lot of
pressure especially on e5 and in the
center and okay so this is just another
way to get there it is pretty typical in
Sicilians like this and maybe you'll
even get to play g4 before you play
Queen to g3 okay so it's a typical
enough move and now black played 'if
I've
okay perhaps he is thinking of Knight to
g4 stuff in the future here and it looks
like okay so he white took first on e5
and then he took on c6 which seems a
little inaccurate so the game went like
this yeah he took and then he took here
so you might very well have just started
with this move if that was your
intention you could take here and then
take care
I mean maybe you'd want to consider
playing f5 but okay if you wanted this
position this perhaps is the way to do
it unless white was figuring in this
position okay I don't mind
Knight takes because that would be the
alternative but would he mind Knight
takes not really sure what he had in
mind okay I mean this guy is a little
weak but you know so is this guy and I
don't really I don't know I mean you've
allowed this variation I don't really
know what it maybe I would have
considered playing this way as as black
but okay so in the game we got we got
this position okay seems fair enough
and now Bishop to d3 alright so I'm not
sure that that's the optimal square for
the bishop I don't see what was why he
avoided this move you know Bishop to c4
that looks like the the more active
diagonal and sometimes black might play
Bishop to e6 and he'll allow the
doubling of pawns probably for the
moment black will just castle but okay I
don't I don't quite see the the point of
putting the bishop on d3 so I think
that's a little timid and okay but
perhaps I guess maybe he played it so he
could Castle queenside I guess that must
be on his agenda but obviously we need
to be careful not to just Castle right
away because I'm seeing stuff like
Bishop to g4 that stuff we need up see
probably not only is you have to put
your Bishop on on d3 but then you
probably have to play a move like h3
before you can Castle queenside
something like that which is a bit slow
and in most lines in the Sicilian when
you do play e4 and F 4 together
and a lot of lines you do end up
castling King side which is just
perfectly fine so okay but it seems like
he has his queenside castling on his
mind and let's see so okay so in this
position this trip to g4 okay and so
this is interesting too he played queen
g3 attacking the e pawn and black
castled so who wants to take the e pawn
let's see if he took it okay so he
played h3 so that's what we'll come back
to you but let's let's just take it for
a second just just to have some fun so I
I mean I'm considering Bishop d6 I'm
considering rook e8 and in intuitively
it just kind of feels pretty risky to
take it we're not castled yet we do get
moves like Bishop d6 I can go to d4 I
can go to g5 those are the only squares
I see I don't and I don't you know see
exactly how we get our pawn back
immediately or something it just it just
sort of feels like Black has a lot of
pressure here so yeah I think it's it's
wise not to just rush in and take that
so instead he he played h3 yeah if
there's any questions or anybody sees
anything again you pawns upon all right
so mario amaya roper yeah you got ain't
gotta risk it to get the biscuit Mario
Rovere all right and then yeah maybe I
don't I don't even quite see it but it
just feels like there's there's so much
pressure here I just there's something
but uh well you know to make sure it was
a it's a true beginner breakdown we need
to make sure we were completely
unprepared for this lecture that was
important that was important alright so
that wasn't taken h3 okay so this is
what happened in the game I think it's a
decent decision and the bishop left its
natural diagonal so yeah okay he went he
went back to h5
and I feel like it's sort of a general
rule that I never hear any other
teachers ever talking about but the
bishops
they tend even if they're going to a
long diagonal if they're not coming out
that way sorry if they're coming out
there
the front door not the back door they
tend to want to stay on their natural
diagonal this is this is kind of where
they like to be so I think I move like
Bishop to e6 makes a lot of sense
because now you're are taking control
over the c-4 square so why can't play
Bishop to c4 himself which ok and you
know you don't want that Bishop on d3
forever if this pawns not gonna move
away so I probably would have stayed I'd
like my pieces in the center and I'd
like to stay on the natural diagonal the
only reason I would go back here which
happened in the game was if I was going
to get some pressure on e4 but uh okay I
don't think that's gonna be too much of
an issue
so we'll see almost so one thing I just
noticed you about h3 is sometimes I can
play here that would be if my my knight
we're out of the way so actually I
wonder I wonder if there's some funny
Knight move on to do funny Knight move
stuff Knight e5
you said you say you say e 5 or D 5 and
Ben Simon's mad because I turned the
sound off so he doesn't get to hear the
illegal click yeah ok yeah I think this
this is a good way to do it in yeah you
got to worry about about this here so
yeah I think this would be interesting
way mm-hmm and then yeah then we yeah
then we get this this looks yeah this
looks unpleasant so yeah I think this so
perhaps there was some some funny stuff
here that we could have attempted but
let's see what was played in the game
Bishop h5 o and perhaps why did notice
these things he played a little queen f2
ok so perhaps perhaps you didn't notice
this this little trick and uh okay again
another move I don't like I don't I
don't know that the reading range of
these players but uh okay rook c8 which
putting me putting the rook right behind
the pawn I suppose the idea is maybe
he's gonna play C 5 C 4 but as soon as
you play C 5 you're giving up control
over some of these light squares so and
I might be able to jump into d5 at some
point if you play c5 immediately maybe
I'll play Bishop c4 stopping your pond
and then I'll a really controlled d5
which will be a nice for me if I were to
move this rook and maybe I would I would
probably just go here to be 8 because
that seems to make a lot of sense and in
a lot of lines where we're castling it
won't let me do it obviously but when
you do that then you know you have to
worry about threats like Queen yet Queen
to a4 very it's a risky move but you
know I've I've directed a lot of
scholastic tournaments so it's it's not
out of the realm of possibility but uh
okay Queen to a5 and you have to start
worrying we want to imagine the king is
castled over there about some sacks here
on b2 those are very typical so well you
got to kind of worry about that I mean I
think castling kingside should be on
White's agenda it seems a little bit
safer but we'll see what happened so
here he played g4
now are there any tricks again yeah this
is I want to move my night out of the
way and play Bishop h4 okay so this move
doesn't doesn't work because I hear we
could we could block but okay we can
still consider moves like Knight to d5
again so the threat is Bishop to h4 and
then yeah you got to do something about
that I know castle or something but then
you lose any lose your your your Bishop
which you probably don't want to do and
now you're you know you played g4 so now
it's it's kind of risky to be castled
over there so we're Nene there were no
tricks played yeah Brooke yeah rook c8
happened
g4 bishop bishop g6 and I guess the
Queen really liked f3 cuz she went back
there so this okay I don't entirely see
the point of this move I think I mean I
probably Castle kingside here it is a
little dicey but I do want to get my my
king out of the center does anyone else
see like better moves if you see better
moves let me let me know but okay Queen
f3 and okay black one for it
he played c5 which okay I think this is
something we can look forward to and
maybe this is why the queen is on f3 to
protect the e4 pawn so you can play
Bishop c4 in this position you know
White's thinking about h4 h5 okay so he
did Castle look at that he castled okay
I assumed you could play c4 right away
of black if that's what you were
intending Queen a5 makes a lot of sense
maybe you'll play rook b8 on the next
move and then take on b2 if it works I
have to make sure it works
okay he played g5
okay so you could move your knife you
could go backwards you probably don't
want to go here because it's on the same
file as the rook I think I'd move my
knight but he he played Bishop h5 so
does this does this work so I'm gonna
move my queen and if you take on team
one they take on f6 and I'm threatening
me and then I'll have time to take back
the bishop on d1 which which I think
should be good for white yeah g5 might
be good yeah maybe we do maybe we should
just you know put the knight back or
something but uh okay this is what was
played and so we'll see yeah so it looks
like looks like this sequence did happen
so Queen g3 and again I suppose you can
move your knight but here White's gonna
get two pieces for the rook so that's
that's a pretty good deal
he took here we took here with a with a
nice little threat I guess black saw it
and okay so he took here so okay that's
a that's a pretty good deal for white we
got we now we got the two bishops we got
two pieces for the exchange and we got
the open G file now so okay I quite like
this now for for Team white over here
c4 root ba yes you're in your idea is to
take on b2 and it works let's let me
pass you want to take care order
Queen takes what we takes Queen takes
yes I don't I don't know if it works but
I mean real takes b2 might be a little
Queen before it's kind of annoying
that's good move that's good move yeah
move cuz I yeah so I guess I have to
start getting ready
okay I'm gonna get ready I'm gonna get
ready here I go no yeah that's actually
quite a quite a scary threat
okay so yeah here let's uh let's give
you your piayed okay Bishop c4 but uh I
don't know maybe still Queen before if
this should be 3 C 4 yeah I wish I
hadn't given you control over D 5 that's
yeah that seems kind of let's say okay
so this this is where we were and now c4
should be 2 and now we're up to be
he played rook to d6 here okay but he
played this move yes this one strikes me
as low it's a little bit weird so I
don't know if it works but I guess it's
fun too
it's fun to give away our pieces see if
it works I'm assuming you can't just
take my bishop but atlas let's have some
fun and let's do this
oh well then at least minimum I'm on
your rook do if I'm not checked meeting
you so okay but I mean I assume that you
can't do this because then I'm going
here
and then I just have to figure out how
to check me you can defend well here
here we have to now get checkmate it
with white okay suppose let's play here
I mean this might be this might be fine
yeah there's this this might be fine
what those boobs look pretty good so
after rook d6 I don't know why he didn't
take on b2 let's see what he will he's
decided to do here there should be seven
was played okay this also might be might
be fine
what would you guys play here with white
I think he played the
Bishop h6 yeah I think that's that's the
obvious move here so you probably have
to play g6 and here you played Queen f3
which is a trick and it looks like it
worked we'll come back to this but it
looks like his trick twerked cuz he went
here and black took this yeah okay
and then yes a black resigned here so it
was a trick and it worked so so that's
good but I wonder okay so first of all
this try to find a better move for black
I'm trying to take on b2 still I think I
still want to take on b2 and you're not
you're not required to take it bringing
this one back to d2 or where yeah and
then is it 95 like a big threat here I
mean this might not be bad but you know
obviously anything is better than then
falling for the little little trap here
see yes this yes that was obviously a
big mistake it was it was a blitz game
so it's understandable that uh those
things happened and yeah I think this
was a pretty good game here I wish we
had seen a couple more sacrifices from
blacks and in this game but I think the
player with white he played reasonably
well I don't know like I said I'd gauge
his strength at somewhere around 14 1500
strength so yeah I think that was a
pretty decent game but now we'll see I
got so many games here we could see
another great game
we could see a game from somebody else
hopefully we get to cover
Craig's game time thanks for sending it
in it was a it was a very good
entertaining game glad we got to go over
it and I read before we began here right
before we began this class I got that
score sheet here from Mario Roper so
this was a game that he played against
India at the bill right open against a
player rated 22:03 so Mario what's you
what's your rating okay so it's a 1,300
and you had black and you're taking on a
2200 so okay
and Mario did not win this game
unfortunately but uh but it's uh it's
okay I think there was a position he he
wanted to talk about something we we get
to examine it
so Knight f3 and Mario decided for a
little piece six is there something you
play often very often alright so if
you're prepping for Mario Roper you
ready for that early b6 and wait decided
here on the movie four so it's it's not
quite gonna be sort of an OH&S defense
where sometimes you've already gotten
the moves
d4 in so after you attack the pawn you
have the move like Bishop d3 to protect
it so that that won't be happening here
so now the pawn is attacked and white
has to make a decision and his opponent
who if only we're here in the audience
he could he could tell us about it he
played the move d3 so it looks like he's
he's probably going in for a Kings
Indian attack cuz I yeah I remember
seeing some of this game so he's gonna
play g3 Bishop g2 and get a get a Kings
Indian attack style position so yes we
are putting upon in front of the bishop
but it's sort of a well known position
that we're gonna get here let's say D D
3e six very reasonable and okay we got a
couple of developing moves here and now
here you played the move h6 which I
don't I don't entirely understand maybe
if you're trying to play Knight f6 are
you worried about like a five or
something maybe you should play a move
like d6
why did you why did you play h6
bad habit okay I mean did you think I
mean even if you applied here and we'll
imagine a five doesn't exist we worried
about a knight or a bishop going to g5
yeah it's bad habit yeah so yeah I think
because you are playing more in like the
open section and you're playing you know
significantly higher rated people now so
yeah and so these are like the little
moves that you're probably trying to
want want to avoid like a sold Knight to
c6 I guess if I were playing it I would
probably want to have my pawn on c5
before I brought my night out but okay
you put them here in front of the pod
and sometimes you do get weird
formations in the Owens where it's you
play you put your pawn here on e5 at
some point and then the night is on c6
and you get a really weird sort of Rui
Lopez where you fianchettoed your bishop
though sometimes you can make it work
you can get sort of weird stuff like
that but uh I don't know if if that's
what we're gonna see in this game late
to c6 linked to c3 okay seems typical
enough and now d6 yeah this seems like a
move you're gonna have to play before
you play Knight to f6
but now your opponent does get the
center so yeah you have spent a little
bit of time you know with h6 and Knight
to c6 you've not really attacked the
center very much in the opening moves so
I think yeah this supposes you some some
interesting problems and now you played
an interesting move that I probably want
to be considered not that it's bad but
uh after Knight f6 does he is a 5 or d5
really annoying here yeah which which
one scares you the most
'if I've
all right so probably you want to trade
Queens cuz you know you're a little bit
behind in development and he's got the
center so I don't yeah I don't know what
he would have would have played if you
were here in the audience what do you
think he would have played not sure not
sure yeah so interesting yeah it feels
like white must have something here
right before black castles d5 yeah this
was sort of when I was a little bit more
worried about as as black I mean I can I
can take once you take about the bond
mm-hmm and yeah I don't know where okay
I mean I guess I'm gonna try to try to
come back into the game of this way I'll
go back to d7 and yeah black's pawn
structure kind of makes a funny
impression and okay the bishop is is
certainly locked out here so I think
it's kind of annoying so in the game
when Mario played here was Bishop to a6
alright so you have attacked the rook
and after the rook moves I'm trying to
understand if this is a better square
certainly there's a lot of stuff in the
way but let's let's be careful here okay
I don't know yeah I don't really know
what the long term term future of this
guy is I'm just kind of worried that now
stuff isn't protected but we'll see what
happened Queen d7 you see a castling
queenside
you know yeah so you're about to Castle
so now this is time to to do something
forceful in the center before you you
get over there
so d5 happened okay yes it feels it
feels quite pleasant for for white here
you played 95
no an interesting movie I guess he saw
you do this so he knew he knew this
maneuver you you had already taught him
bishop h3c so yeah this is you teaching
the master right he learned from the
best
okay now there's no Knight g4 stuff and
there is a lot of pressure on e6 so I
think this this move is actually a very
good move I think it's yeah that's a
very very good move
it says castles King side but okay
obviously obviously one Queen side yes
and now 94 there's there's a lot of
pressure on e6 he's also thinking maybe
like f4 and then he can put his knight
on c6 so you're not you're not out of
danger here already yeah well you got
your yeah your king and queen on the
same diagonal here so you got your your
King out but now what to do after this
move it's just this is this is just bad
maybe even even winning for white you
know this is just this is not good so if
you take you can probably take back with
this night I assume so this didn't
happen because that you were gonna take
up tonight or the bishop they're both
they're both so good or you'd play f4
and not do either one of them and then
there's yeah okay so I kind of
understand you just you decided to give
him upon cuz there looks like there's a
lot of danger if you take that so yeah
so in this position you didn't play f4
because of c5
but I mean you can probably take here
right
you you didn't like this one this looks
pretty good
maybe I don't have to take there maybe I
couldn't do something else but it looks
pretty good Detroit it does it is like a
little a little loosey goosey because
there's some weaknesses in your camp
mm-hmm no I mean I think it's just yeah
it makes makes total sense here to take
on e6 because if he takes back did you
did you have something in mind if you
took back did you know which way you
were gonna take care yeah you can take
yeah I can take with either thing and
okay they both look pretty good f4 is
probably good ignoring everything like
I'll just develop my pieces maybe that's
even good yeah you probably do anything
here also yeah how do you protect it
like let me just this pretend I'm not
not making the best move here or
anything I'm just like just still what
are you gonna do about e6 you know so
it's it's yeah so very pleasant which is
why Mario decided to give up a pond okay
Queenie eight and okay so instead of
taking now you play that for is this was
it this position Mario where you wanted
to talk about here or is that is it
coming up is this position we were
talking about you were looking at this
did you have a line so you're just
wondering about what would happen here
so maybe you're on a great day you'd
play c5 his knight would move away and
then you'd for him but I don't know what
happens after this but okay so that that
didn't happen after this he played a F
for not a lot of places to go so sort of
compelled to play the move c5 here
and the night went to f5 there's
anything else 90-95 seems matter 5 seems
quite good ok 9f v g6 so you're begging
him to take also you probably want him
to take on g7 man this is yeah this is
not good at this point so ok took your
night is still hanging
you took this night and he took here
yeah terrible how could you ruin your
pawn structure like that just just awful
just awful okay but when you're winning
lots of stuff it's pretty good okay so
black tooks here so uh you know we got a
little white black white it's pretty
good pretty good it's pretty it's a
pretty picture so you argue guys are
chess artists out there so that's good
to know
after this sorry I wasn't he takes takes
Queen what happened after this move
oh yeah it must mean it must be here
because yeah the next move is hmm yes
the next move is is this move here
mm-hmm did you think of another move I'm
get your queen out or something just
Queenie to or something yeah Queen G for
mm-hmm so I don't know what can I can I
be so crazy so if you take on that v
movie I'll take back with my knight and
then maybe I get to jump into d4 you
know and yeah you can even play Queen e2
did you have you have a suggestion here
you know about f5 I'm I'm getting
crushed what you want me to do I'm just
I'm hoping I get to go here and then I
get to go here and maybe I get a good
night it's just it's a it's a dream it's
a dream you know mm okay so instead this
move was played very very good and you
took back mm-hmm okay yeah so after this
yeah I like his Bishop c8 this looks
this looks good can I somehow get your
get your bishop
right yeah so yeah if you ever have this
time here so I'm trying to get this
piece back yes a rock f1
so can I just go back to e8 is that 1-1
Queens you were looking at this during
the game
Queen takes rook and then it's like an
either take organ
should I take here first I'm in check so
you so his handsome dancers know all
right which and then then I don't know
how to take back okay okay so this would
happen mm-hmm yeah still quite difficult
for for wait to win and okay at least we
got this this square but yeah but yeah
what yeah what happens on this one why
don't you play this move did you
consider this move yeah cuz it's okay
yeah cuz again yeah here's here's the
idea the Queen gets trapped and you know
so that okay she goes back then we we
obviously get to take this this looks a
little bit better I don't even I don't
even know who's better now I don't know
what's going on anymore
maybe blacks better so maybe this was
your this is maybe this is your big
chance you know taking on a master Mario
that's it
see cuz you knew you you probably know
my rule of always play Queen da but you
didn't know of the the corollary always
play Queen EA yeah that's me yeah so
yeah the question is what was your your
time situation
plenty of time just didn't yeah I mean
there's lots of stuff you can take the
rook you can take the Queen mm-hmm right
yeah yeah I guess he perhaps you just
you just didn't see did you just not did
you see this move or it's a hard move to
see you know mm-hmm and then yeah here
so yeah yep yeah a little Queenie ain't
no Queenie ain't alright okay son said
you played here okay so what's weights
off the hook a little bit okay yeah so
the Queen's attacked h4a said yes and
after g5 the Queen's not trapped we have
h5 and then there's yeah that's just not
trapped g5 I was playing g5 including h5
and you went right back okay so yeah you
didn't trade you went back over here and
then and then the bishop moved and you
check mated them oh darn didn't happen
after a little this basics okay he
developed his pieces darn I hate when
they just develop their pieces Queen
before and now an interesting thing I
guess
I think most people will consider doing
with this rook but okay he went this way
right the rook was attacked so he moved
it and he'll probably get to play moves
like a 3 and B 4 in the future opening
up your your king size your King on the
Queen side over here alright your Bishop
just you can't really decide you know
he's trying to keep his options open in
life he's willing to explore new
possibilities you know mmm ok let's kind
of annoying this is okay and you play c4
I don't really know where to put the
night but okay see for a three and you
had to go back to an open file so no
rook to d1 at some moment it was played
immediately 31 which will at least
exchange a lot of stuff Queen c7 and
another annoying move what did I what
did white play here might be five and
it's quite annoying so okay you were you
felt compelled to take this so yeah I
don't know how your you know it might be
a goner Queen c6 hoping for this no I
don't know he just take so after this
actually did see I was watching this
live so I didn't see this move so I came
over and uh I figured it out but uh what
did white play here to finish the game
off that was a good little puzzle here
rook d1 yeah so it's just this just
finishes the game first of all if you
take here second of all if you play here
okay not only are you losing your rook
but you're probably getting checkmated
and even like this it's not maybe
there's a more forceful way but even
this looks incredibly winning hmm
I don't know do you know the fastest way
to mate here did you look it up
I assume it's mate in four or five or
something maybe even just take the rope
or something but okay I kind of like
this move the more I think about it the
more I like that move so okay but yeah
that was a good game Mario you came you
came so close you came so close I guess
a very good player and yet you can keep
sending in your games well I'll probably
sometimes for even when I'm doing the
strategy class I know people like to
have their games analyzed so if you like
this go ahead and send in your games too
info at st. Louis chess club org and
maybe your your game will get to be
showed up here hopefully we get to come
back watch some of these other games in
the next coming weeks here and yeah so
if you have any ideas some sort of
strategic ideas maybe you'd like to see
in a class in the next couple weeks let
me know hit like share subscribe and
thanks everybody for coming out tonight
you